votre vidéo vous est présenté par
victoria tirer talents.com vous avez
plus de 5000 followers sur vos réseaux
sociaux
venez nous rejoindre et devenez
influenceurs grâce à victoria tirait
talents.com ce matin je suis regardé sur
ses news on dirait gilbert montagné qui
est derrière sirène oyonnax parce que je
suis adepte de soleil si pékin drôle ça
fait rire je te vois tu as fait rire tu
as quelque chose à dire vous voulez rire
tu ris quand je ris tuerie quand je ris
bon bon alors tout horizon une wii knee
voudrais quand même le bobigny valu
beaucoup de poids
voilà je vous laisse aller voir sur le
site regarder comment ces propos vous
aimez moi j'adore c'est bien mais
j'avais 20 ans et depuis quand tu me
voyais pas ce que tu as fait trois jours
pour moi tu vois avant boeing mais bon
j'en finis qu'elle est finie j'ai défini
et à combien le thé l'add on ne sait
rien mais ton doigt
32 37 liberty and à 37 c la température
d'un q c'était pas la température date
et c'est pas possible car avec tout au
sexe bien évidemment certains qu 37 tu
le sais ça capte devrait le savoir thé
spécialisé chaud dans la quête et
spécialisés
[Musique]
il
amy retour sortie de l'émission team
caris n'oublie jamais vim
on a trouvé notre vers un nouvel agent
d'entretien amis je suis avec le public
des touches papilles ans de folie et
c'est le seul on est dans le gai
dans le guette les bases du tout serein
5 et 6 passes d'évacuation on se
retrouve avec bernard les yeux
donc en fait moi j'arrive chez vous et
c'est fou qu'on regarde pas ses actes a
démarré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
admiration
éduquer au monde
voilà
général mais chantal ans m omar ba à la
référence et quelques animaux ce
technicien là calmos d'accord
allez qui je suis alors cette coiffure
comment comptes-tu la vie il faut pas
mal pour l'instant qu'un petit truc vers
la paix les gens sont très gentils et
aime beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
qui vont bon train
les choses à gérer
ok merci à optique belleville pour les
lunettes parce que grâce à ses lunettes
à regarder ils sont là ils savent pas
quand je me lève optique bâle ville
je vous aime ne l'oubliez jamais alain
view on était près de moi et c'est dans
mon sillage vous allez vivre vos rêves
[Musique]